نريد الآن أن نعرض لكم إحدى
مراحل المأساة التي تتكشف
في السودان ونتحدث عن الثمن الذي
تدفعه العديد من العائلات بعد فقدان
أحبائهم، نغوا خالد حمد، وهي طبيبة
قُتلت في قذيفة هاون على
منزلها في الخرطوم في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر.
ابنها خالد عثمان الموجود أيضًا في تلك
الصورة التي تنظر إليها هناك
مع والده ينضم إلينا الآن من مسقط
في عمان، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على التحدث
معنا في هذا الوقت الصعب والمأساوي، ونقدم
تعازينا العميقة لك
ولعائلتك على  فقدان
والدتك،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك وأنا أقدر ذلك، لذا
تحدث إلينا عما حدث
لوالدتك التي كانت أيضًا طبيبة كما
ذكرنا مثل والدك،
ما هي الظروف المحيطة
بوفاتها،
كانت أمي تجلس في
غرفة معيشتها  منزلنا في كارلتون نورث في
كوبر
كانوا يسمعون بداية
سماع أصوات الطلقات النارية
والإفصاحات العالية في الخلفية، لقد
اعتادوا نوعًا ما على الإعجاب بهذه
الطلقات النارية الآن ولكن كل شيء
تضاعف مرتين، أنت تعرف كل شيء  كان الصوت
أعلى وكان كل شيء أقرب
وأتذكر آخر شيء كانت
تقوله أمي عندما كانت ترسل لنا
عبر الدردشة الجماعية على الواتساب،
كانت تسجل صوت الانفجارات العالية على
إطلاق النار
حتى نتمكن من سماعها وكان الصوت عاليًا للغاية، كما
شعرت  وكأنني أعيش هناك، شعرت
وكأنني هناك، شعرت وكأنني معهم، في
دقيقة واحدة كانت أمي تسجل
إطلاق النار، وبعد أقل من نصف ساعة
لم تكن
كذلك، لذا ما حدث كان
بمثابة
رأس المحرك خارج منزلنا مباشرةً أو
على السياج مباشرة ودخلت إحدى المباري
عبر النوافذ وحطمت النوافذ ووصلت
إلى أمي،
كانت أمي أمي وأخي في
غرفة المعيشة معًا وهربوا
إلى منزلي  غرفة أبي وهربت،
نهضت وهربت
ثم أدركت لاحقًا أنها كانت كما لو كان
لدي شيء ما على رقبتي، وأعتقد أن لدي
دماء على رقبتي وكان
لديها القليل جدًا من الدم على رقبتها
ولم تفعل ذلك حتى  أدركت شيئًا
ثم انهارت فجأة،
حاول والدي إجراء الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي لها،
لكن الوقت كان متأخرًا جدًا، أقل من
دقيقتين، كانت
ميتة بالفعل،
أنا آسف جدًا لخسارتك
وأعلم أنك تحدثت سابقًا عما
حدث.  لقد تحدثت عنها طبيبة لطيفة،
في بعض الأحيان لم يتمكن العديد من مرضاها
حتى من تحمل تكاليف خدماتها
كطبيبة، وقد قدموا لها الطعام والعديد من
العناصر الأخرى لدفع ثمن
خدمتها لهم كطبيبة تحدث إلينا
عما  يحدث الآن لأخيك وأختك
وبالطبع والدك هل
سيبقون في السودان أم أنهم
يخططون للخروج والانضمام إليك هناك في
عمان
خلال الأسبوع الماضي.
لا أستطيع الراحة لا
أستطيع التنفس بشكل صحيح أشعر
أن هناك شيئًا ما
يضغط على قلبي لأنني
لا أستطيع الحزن بشكل صحيح أو على أمي ولا
أستطيع أن
أشعر بالأمان على والدي من أجلي  كان والدي وأخي
وأختي
عالقين في منزلهم لأنني
أعتقد أنه انسحب للتو لأكثر من 50 ساعة
وكانوا يحاولون
الصمود في وجه إطلاق النار وتلك
الانفجارات لأنه لم يكن
الخروج آمنًا ولحسن الحظ لم يكونوا كذلك
هل
كانوا محظوظين بما فيه الكفاية ليجدوا
الوقت الكافي لدفن أمي والعودة
لكنهم ظلوا عالقين في المنزل
لأكثر من 50 ساعة ثم
أخذ والدي أخي وأختي إلى
أه
أعتقد أن الجانب الحديث من الرسوم المتحركة حيث
إنه  كان الأمر أكثر أمانًا بعض الشيء وقد بقي
مع
بعض الأقارب هناك،
لكنني سمعت أنني أعلم أن الأمر
صعب عليك بشكل خاص لأنك
تراقب من بعيد مما يزيد من
صعوبة معرفة ما يحدث
مع عائلتك.  سأكون مهتمًا
بمعرفة رد فعلك على هذا الصراع ووقف
إطلاق النار الهش للغاية الذي
يبدو أنه صامد في بعض أجزاء
البلاد على الأقل، لكن ماذا تقول
للقائدين العسكريين اللذين كانا
يتقاتلان من أجل السيطرة على البلاد؟
أريد أن أقول إنني لست
شخصًا سياسيًا على الإطلاق، أنا لا
أنتمي إلى أي حزب سياسي، لا
أهتم بأي حزب سياسي ولكن ما
يهمني هو الأشخاص الأبرياء الذين يموتون
بسبب هذا الصراع  أنا لا أنتمي إلى أي
منهم، أريدهم فقط أن يتوقفوا
لأنني أشعر أن
المطورين الوحيدين الذين
يعانون من هذا هم بعض
المدنيين في المنتصف الذين
يقعون في مرمى النيران المتبادلة وفي بعض الأحيان لا يتم
القبض عليهم حتى  في تبادل إطلاق النار،
أحيانًا يتم استهدافهم مثل بعض
الأطباء، بعض العائلات البريئة التي
يحاولون الهرب، لقد تعرضوا لإطلاق النار
في وسط تبادل إطلاق النار، أصيبوا بإطلاق النار،
أصيبوا بالرصاص وهم
يركبون سياراتهم أثناء محاولتهم الهرب، لقد
كنت محظوظًا بما فيه الكفاية  أن يهرب والدي وأبي
وأخي وأختي
هذا الصباح إلى الجانب الشمالي من
البلاد،
لكن تلك كانت
رحلة مخيفة للغاية بالنسبة لهم وشعرت
وكأنني بالكاد أستطيع التنفس مرة أخرى، كما تعلمون،
أشعر بذلك  أنت تتحدث باسم معظم الناس
هناك في السودان، ومرة ​​أخرى أنا آسف جدًا،
تعازينا العميقة لك
ولعائلتك لفقد والدتك
خالد عثمان، شكرًا جزيلاً لك، شكرًا جزيلاً لك.